we humans have many defining moments in
our lives sometimes these moments are
joyous and sometimes are heartbreaking
tragic but at these defining moments if
we are able to make the right choice we
literally manifest a miracle in us and
others my only son tarik a university
student a kind generous a good writer a
good photographer had aspirations to
work for National Geographic engaged to
a beautiful lady worked as a pizza
delivery man on Fridays and Saturdays he
was lured to a bogus address by a youth
gang and in a gang initiation of 14 year
old shot and killed him the sudden
senseless death of an innocent unarmed
human being the or whelming grief of her
family the total confusion as you try to
absorb a new hideous reality needless to
say it brought my life to a crashing
halt one of the hardest things I've ever
had to do is to call his mother who
lived in a different City how do you
tell her mother she's never gonna see
her son again
or hear him laugh or give him a hug I
practice as a Sufi Muslim I have
meditate two hours a day and sometimes
in deep trauma and deep tragedy there is
a spark of clarity so what I downloaded
in my meditation is that there were
victims at both ends of the gun it's
easy to see that my son was a victim of
the 14 year old they were complicated to
see that he was a victim of American
society and that begs the question well
who is American society well it's you
and me because I don't believe that
society just happenstance I think
they're always
ansible for the society we've created
and children killing children is not a
mark of a civil society so nine months
after Tareq died I started Atari camisa
foundation in our mandate at the Tariq
khamisa foundation is to stop kids from
killing kids by breaking the cycle of
youth violence and essentially of three
mandates are first and foremost is to
save lives of children it's important to
do we lose so many on a daily basis our
second mandate is to empower the right
choices so kids don't fall through the
crack and choose lives of gangs and
crime and drugs and alcohols and weapons
and our third mandate is to teach the
principles of non-violence of empathy of
compassion of forgiveness and I'll start
with a very simple premise that violence
is a learned behavior no child was born
violent if you accept that as a truism
non-violence can also be a learned
behavior but you have to teach it
because kids are not going to learn that
through osmosis
so now after that I reached out to my
brother here with the attitude we both
lost a son my son died he lost his
grunts into the adult prison system and
I asked him to join me and as you see 22
years later was still here together as I
can't bring Tariq back from the dead you
can't take Tony out of prison but the
one thing we can do is make sure no
other young people in our community end
up dead or end up in prison with the
grace of God the target can be saw
Foundation has been successful we have a
safe school model first which has four
different programs the first one is
alive assembly with flares and me where
introduce this man grants until this men
Sun and here they are together we have
in classroom curriculum we are
after-school mentoring program and we
create a peace Club and I'm happy to
share with you that besides teaching
these principles of non-violence
we are able to cut suspensions and
expulsions by 70% which is huge which is
here five years after Tareq died and for
me to complete my journey of forgiveness
I went to see the young man who killed
my son he was 19 years old and I
remember that meeting because we were
he's 37 still in prison but at that
first meeting we locked eyeballs I'm
looking in his eyes he's looking in my
eyes and I'm looking in his eyes trying
to find a murder and I didn't I was able
to climb through his eyes and touch his
humanity that I got that the spark in
him was not different than the spark in
me or anybody else here so I wasn't
expecting that he was remorseful he was
articulate he was well mannered and I
could tell that my hand or forgiveness
had changed him so with that please
welcome my brother please Tony
it's my one and only daughter's one and
only child Tony was born to my daughter
who was 15 when she gave birth to Tony
mothering is the toughest job on the
planet
there is no tougher job on the planet
than raising another human being and
making sure they're safe secure and well
positioned to be successful in life
Tony experienced a lot of violence in
his life as a young kid he saw one of
his favorite cousins be murdered in the
hail of web automatic weapon fire and
gang involvement in Los Angeles he was
very traumatized in so many different
ways Tony came to live with me I wanted
to make sure he had everything a kid
needed to be successful but on this
particular evening after years of being
with me and struggling mightily to try
to be successful and to live up to my
expectations of being a successful
person on this one particular day Tony
ran away from home that evening he went
to be with people he thought was friends
he was given drugs and alcohol and he
took them because he thought they would
make him feel carefree
but all it did was to make his anxiety
go higher and to creat up more a more
deadly thinking on his part he was
invited to a robbery he was given a
9-millimeter handgun and at the presence
of an 18 year old who commanded him and
two fourteen-year-old boys he thought
were his friends he shot and killed 2
riku me so this man's son there are no
words there are no words that can
express the loss of a child and my
understanding that my grandson was
responsible for the murder of this human
being I went to the prayer closet like I
was taught by my old folks and began to
pray and meditate the one thing to mr.
camisa and I have in common and we
didn't know this besides being wonderful
human beings that we both meditate it
was very helpful for me because it
offered me an opportunity to seek
guidance and clarity about how I wanted
to be of support of this man and his
family in this loss and sure enough my
prayers were answered because I was
invited to a meeting at this man's house
met his mother his father his wife his
brother met their family and had a
chance to be in the presence of God
spirited people led by this man who in
the spirit of forgiveness made way made
an opportunity for me to be a value and
to share with him and to share with
children the importance of understanding
the need to be with a responsible adult
focus on your anger in a way that's
healthy learn to meditate the programs
that we have and Tariq khamisa
foundation provides so many tools to the
kids to put in their toolkit so they
could carry on them throughout their
lives it's important that our children
understand that loving caring adults
care for them and support them was also
important are our children learn to
meditate learn to be peaceful learn to
be centered and learn to interact with
other children and a kind empathetic and
wonderfully loving way we need more love
in our society and that's why we're here
to share the love with children because
our children
will lead the way for us because all of
us will depend on our children as we
grow older and retire they will take
over this world for us so as much love
as we teach them they will give their
back to us blessings thank you so I was
born in Kenya was educated in England
and my brother here is a Baptist I
practiced as a Sufi Muslim he's
african-american but I always tell him
I'm the African American in the group I
was born in Africa you were not and I'm
not for this as a as a citizen I'm a
first generation citizen and I felt that
as an American citizen I must take my
share of the responsibility for the
murder of my son why because it was
fired by an American child you could
take the position he killed my one and
only son he should be hung from the
highest pole how does that improve
society and I know you're probably
wondering what happened to that young
man he's still in prison we just turned
37 on September the 22nd but I have some
good news we've been trying to get him
out for 12 years we finally will join us
a year from now
and I'm very excited to have him join us
because I know we've saved him but he
will save tens of thousands of students
when he shares his testimony in schools
that we are president on a regular basis
when he says to the kids when I was 11 I
joined a gang when I was 14 I murdered
mr. Kinesis son I've spent the last
umpteen years in prison I'm here to tell
you is not worth it do you think the
kids were listening to that voice yes
because his in donations will be of a
person that pulled the trigger and I
know that he wants to turn the clock
back of course that's not possible I
wish it was I would have my son back my
brother would have his grandson back so
I think that demonstrates the power of
forgiveness so what's the big takeaway
here some when I and our session with
this quote which is the basis of my
fourth book which incidentally the
foreword for that book was written by
Tony so it goes like this sustained
goodwill creates friendship you don't
make friends by bombing them right you
make friends by extending goodwill that
ought to be obvious so sustain goodwill
creates friendship sustain friendship
creates trust sustain trust creates
empathy sustain empathy creates
compassion and sustained compassion
creates peace I call this my peace
formula starts with goodwill friendship
trust empathy compassion and peace but
people ask me how do you extend goodwill
to the person who murdered your child I
tell them you do that through
forgiveness as it's evident it worked
for me it worked for my family what's a
miracle is it work for Tony
it worked for his family can work for
you and your family for Israel in
Palestine North and South Korea for Iraq
Afghanistan Iran in Syria it can work
for the United States of America so let
me leave you with this my sisters and a
couple of brothers
that piece is possible how do I know
that because I am at peace thank you
very much
namaste
[Applause]
[Music]